So here's how I got it as a computer
science student, you share my code and you know
contribute in the community today well so
here we are going to learn in today's video
how you can also get it as a computer science student by
doing it in different ways.  Skills and
your work flow i.e.
sharing the code with anyone, pushing it to anyone in your community,
how to send a full request,
these are very basic things, today we are going to
learn in this video so my name
is Surya watching code text  Let's Get
Started
[Music]
So first of all we know Get and Get Up
you do it and why to
introduce Okay so it is about the year 2005
when people used to carry pen drives from here and there and walk
four kilometers to share the code.
Brother, this is the code for the fort at my friends' house. If you try it, you will start facing
a lot of problems. There is a
distance of 5-5 kilometers, 10-10 kilometers, people are not aware of this, the
story was something else.  You must have heard
about the Lyrics Operating System when
it was being made. It was being made in real life
and was being introduced to the
world, so there was less for it, that is,
its code could be kept at one place and anyone could
download it.  So that they could run it in their system
where that technology was being used
[Music], the
name of which is a
very interesting story, so what they did was to
withdraw the license, which means they are
providing the license for free,
if there is any open source software in it.
Third party YouTube was done
and what happened after that, after that the
big magic came that now they
could not have the pet software like that because inside it, they tried to
reduce the meaning of this thing
[music]
and made it a real  Life
should be learned for this reason, what is there in it. If
we understand like, get and get up, then
this is also a version distribution system, which
means you will put your course at one place and
can send it to anyone and he can download it.  You
can open your file in any form and view it
easily on the same platform. This thing was
created because you had to go on a bicycle or
even by plane to cover a distance of 4 kms. So, click OK
on a page like this.  As you
enter, here you go, then go to direct.com, for
this account, I will make it my new Gmail.
Heavy, this is my new Gmail. I had
just created it for you to understand in a better way,
how to make a new account.
Here, when you
go to ID or search someone's ID, you
search only by most preferred or user name. This is the only public way for you.
Here, it means the entire all over the
world. Your user name is shown to others.  If I
say so, I have
put something like this here
Product Related
Ok dear count
ok dear
353 50212 [
music]
So what do you want to do Automation are you
interested in client apps then choose
van of days like I have to work in the community
Forget up  Student So Gas Here Special
Tips If you are any student then you
can directly go here and you can also access it
by using your college email id and just adding some
documents also and verification after
date you will be able to do that.  On the student
develop side,
here you will keep your complete account for free. At this
time, if you
look at your right hand side father's corner, here you will see your complete
profile, that
is, how many stars you have got, if
any of you like, if anyone
likes the project.  Aap star deta hai
and you make it un known you be less popular
on this also ok so here is a very
good interface on getup from here you
can direct,
whoever you follow here will also follow you here.  You
can do it like your
boss is
doing any work, you can see your project,
here you get pull
request, you
can see many issues in the market place, here
you can directly search any code
related.  Like, if you want Python
projects, then
you can directly search for Python projects here,
here we will learn,
your complete account is setup, you
see how to create the wrap in the most basic step
and very easily.
How to upload any file inside this is a
very simple method, so
here we will talk further
about it, before that we will
finish the entire installation once,
first of all we know that we have to give
a gift.  How to install: So let's
install the get like our easy key
and how you
[Music]
Drag and drop features Father PS2
Get and Get up India Project
and Stone
Search for Windows version here Like you
go here download
here application  You will download it from
here and download an application like mine here,
you also make changes there, but you do
not like those changes, you have to revert them,
you can do it by controlling the time,
but we make these changes when your system is off.
Once that change is done, you cannot do it at the Dhaba, so what
can you do as a gift? What does the kit
do? If you are also changing it, then
before changing the thing, he records it.
You must have heard his entry.
Okay, so the gift here was my download,
so I am removing the previous one and installing it,
so after its installation, we will see
how
you have to configure the new things in the kit
and how you can get it in your system, so
here is a lot of information.  Everything is done.
Best end view of launch. Release notes.
I am not doing anything here please nor do I want to open it. We will finish
it and it's over. Dan,
we have got the get installed, you
can verify with this, you will direct the
soap here.  But we will talk about how we
create a repo, the steps are very simple,
you will go back to your getup itself and create a
repo. Appreciately, you will get it on this interface,
here you will get your opinion
related to your project and if you want to give any feedback.
You can give that, so here you
can see,
you can take the name as per your choice, like
I give here anything like
[music], whether you want to
keep it private, whether you want to keep it public, it
is up to you, you can also give its description.
This is optional, it is
beneficial that you are giving a description, but
you can include the code that you are deleting
in the description or
you can also put it in a file such that you can have a
long description so that people can easily understand
it.  Project is your code here,
what do you want to show
then support here I am choosing private
or means anyone like what do
you do in public like your ID is public, if we
take the example of Instagram somewhere then
you have to follow there.  And this
here is also in private, who can see and
comment to date, it will be visible to people only
if you have
accepted him or sent him a request
and he is invited or not, so
here in other vans anyone can give public.
Here, I will remain public for now,
then add the file here, here you can add
this long description about it, like I
told you, from the video to
you and video
images and all these things related to the
court.  And inside this,
you can create any software of your own so that
people can
run it and if you
want to keep some description of how to run it, then
you can do that, here there are gift ignore
templates, like
here, what is your code related to?  So
here you will find many things like
pipe and triple ok now you can do as per your choice
ok so here you can do anything for this
we will leave it blank for now it is
making a very simple reform you
can keep it in the license if  You have to keep the license. My
TVS TVS TV is a simplified license, which
means it is open source like
HD license, so it is open shot, it is easy for you, it is a
big company, whatever they
work on the license only, we have
this license.  Here you can leave the license leave it
blank if you want to share update you have you know
first grade
how to do you have to upload
or create
comments how you have to upload that file
how to do so I go here
create  If you come here on New File or Upload and New
File, then there will be an
option to select your file here, then you
can directly drop the drag and drop it, so
how will we do one, if you click directly on it,
then it will go to your system.
Comment here.  I want you can tell me
what has been uploaded, here you will
see that
this is changed for this, I have
changed this image so that
this image gets changed in my HTML page, if you have
kept any other image in the other image.  So here you
can change something like this, if you
change the direct comment here then it will become a comment
and this will start showing your recovery as to what
you have to bring, then here a
review file and screenshot has been taken like
you  If you add anything like screenshot, image etc. then
it will also be shown to you here as to what you have put.
Okay then this is simply a dragon
drop feature, here you
can also add more of your files,
for that you have to divide it into partitions.  It is
not a long process, you can use a big
software,
I wrote the code, after changing the line, I have to
upload the code on Getup, change
it in this code, then this feature
is there, like drop, so for that, we
do the gift here.
More functionality for control,
so we are back on our YouTube, let's see the
second method which is kit, here we are going to
talk about gate, basically
what is gate, gate is a version control system,
okay and gate off which is our one
royaljan.  It is a distributed system, that is, it is
distributed all over the world, anyone
can do it, they can send their court to Getup
and other van can access it. Okay, this is
so simple, you will have to understand and
what is version control system which is Getup.
This is our version control system, that is, what
I told you earlier in this video is that if
you are working in any application,
you have to change it and the
thing which you have to revert means
you have to go back because there is something in it.  If there is an error, then to
control it, we
use this kit here, it
gives us many features that
you can send directly to Pushkar, which is a
distributed system, so the entire
work flow is controlled there.  Which
our data does like creator
repersultry,
you will see in this part how to setup that
and here we will
create a wrapper, create a folder
inside which we will do some code,
how should we set the code and how to push.  Do
all the coding that we have done, we are
changing anything, inside it we will
see some very simple work that gate and gate is yours,
how to do it, so here what we are going to do is
create a gift, you can name anything
so.  Like I have given a test van and I am
directly here,
like I have given a refrigerator of the test van,
inside which a command line is
given which is saying this is this kit, you
can gift it here, go to your local
system and where  You have to
enter this code, you have to push it,
wherever you are on any system, you directly sign
in and here you wrap it, you are
not doing it in your local system, someone else's
system is doing it and that code.  If you
want it then you can directly get it from where but you will have to keep in
mind about the gift for which your user
name and password is set or if you want to know the user name and
Gmail ID
in global and better then there
can be a complete command for that, shell etc. if you want.  Want to
learn? Govinda comment ok gas,
here is going to be a very simple process.
When you install the kit then
you have done the process here. So here we
create a very simple folder
basically here inside which  We will do a little
coding, like a small spyden file
or a small key file,
you can do anything, you can also create an HTML file,
so here I give it a name
like yesterday
so here I give a name.  Given this,
what will I do,
here I create a file with a nice name,
simple, here, what will I do, here
I
write my like or anything inside, nice
print it here or anything OnePlus
2 You  You can write anything inside it.
Now in the learning process, create a small file
and whatever thing you
want to implement, implement it in the thing and
see how it is being implemented. If
you understand the working of the thing.  If
you want to know how to use it easily in a big project,
then
no one is going to stop you in a different page, you have to
go and try it, maybe it can be implemented, if
not, then C can be implemented with this thing,
OK
print Hello OK without
using other drop feature.  And if I
change anything in this code, after means once I have
given my command, any
change I am making after this should be implemented,
meaning it should detect the change and
how to do that
which you have seen in the video.  And
I follow the same process in my daily
projects, whether I am
working on any project in any company, whether I am making
changes
in like software or in open source software,
then there you get all the things,
mostly the company gets it done.
Control date version of D application OK, if
you make any such interpol mistake, it can be
reverted through version control
system thoughts, the same get it and this is
very popular all over the world OK, to
run it, you will try, you will initiate it,
OK here we will use it  Those who do it, first of all
we will initiate that here I want a gift,
I want a get inside this folder, so
what do we do for that, one there is this
un command initiate get,
so what un, what is the tension in this, like if you
initiate, then he changed.  Meaning like it used to be
green which was white before me,
here all these things are happening from the gift side and
also after we get initiated, what
happened after getting initiated, a folder has become a
staging area,
stitching area like gift is needed, birthday
means
terminology.  If you can forget then
what is happening inside it like suppose you
went to the terminal and you have means your flight and you have to
go there, that is your teasing area
okay
and when you are going from the airport that
is your local computer means  For example, I am
going from a terminal in India and somewhere else I have a
location in another world, so
assume that the other
location in the world is my getup,
then that terminal is my local system i.e.
local computer, now local computer system is
required.  So
here, when I go to the view, you will
not be able to see it, then if you click on the hidden items, it will be
written here, then
you will start seeing it. Okay, so
Get Initiate means this whole
process has happened behind the command. Here you have seen what
I have seen.  If we have told you, then keep this thing
in mind that we are detailing it, so
now what we have to do after this is that we have to
add as many files as we have, that is, if we have a
file with go dot po, then to add it.  It is
a simple command
so here add get so
you can also add a specific file
but here you can start me specification [
music]
just
gives the feature as a gift get which is so
what are we going to do here now  Add, we do
n't have to file review, we have to do that file directly
there,
which is not available in the repo in our name, so what will we do here,
get,
what are we doing here, now we are
preparing a message when  If he goes up
i.e. goes like a rope, there will
be a plane land like us, then there is an option of checking there,
when we check, it should be written
that
why are we here at the time of immigration, why are we here for the purpose of job, we are such
tourists
who go with this message.  Here at the
time of immigration, we will show
what we have to do like this, I have come here to
take change, this is my second change or
second
application, here you
can also send any message, it is always sent along with it.  The
first comment is OK, you
can change it
here, after this we will move towards the next command, then
here you have to tell us
in which branch, here we have chosen min
because with this you will be able to reduce whatever folder you are
in.
So you will have to tell a location where you want to
go, so for that we will give
you an idea that praise
ID, here you will get many ways,
one Acidity PS which is
one by the name of Dot Kit.  You also get the version, whatever
you enable from the cloud, like you learn
cloud like A&S or
in cloud computing, then there we
do this, we do that, you know interact between different
machines, okay,
so we will come here, we will put it here.  But
Get Remote has already been added and whenever you create a Repu here,
you will get a new
HTTPS address,
then you have to enter that address here
and this command will always be there. Get
Remote is being added, so like  You just said
that this is my address brother, leave it on this address and come back,
whatever file we give,
enter it here and it has been added,
we have already got the file
which is stitched, on which address
it has to be sent.
She is already telling in the original,
go to the branch, brother and push, okay
with the comment, so this is the direct
[music] here
and after writing here, we have set everything,
now you have to see that our file is gone.  Or
else we go directly here, here we will
click again on the code,
as if we clicked, you
will come to some such interface like we saw in the Dragon Drop one,
so in the Dragon Drop one, we
saw this by doing the direct
and drop.  As for the butt,
what we saw here is that we have added some gift with the command
and from that the first message has come here and
along with it, this message has also come cool
comment, so here we can write anything,
something inside its folder.  And I will change it
and go directly here
[Music]
I did not create a file here in which I will name it
Go
Van Dot
Application, you
can do many things here,
I told print, brother, it
is ok
[Music]
What do I have to do, that's it  I have done all the
procedures
here, I will come down in the terminal and
repeat all these procedures for me again,
I will go,
okay, now you like, if there is any problem,
then you can tell me a commando, I will give you the
gift
status,
you can check it, gift.
What is the status? Look at the status, is this a new file in the gift, is there
any file which is not ticked, like this
you can check by doing the status,
you must be seeing our stack, the stage is done,
okay, you are in that stage, okay.  One
file has been staged, get stored, end 2
uninstation, ok, now this file is ready to go,
ok, what will we do now, we will
call it brother comment, Amit,
instead of cool comment, I will give you some more comments which will help
you understand more.  What is the message, let me
add it there by doing
something like this, let's end it, nine,
you give me the
origin path, everything is already set, the branch
is also set, so I have to push directly, okay,
how can you see, you
will get the answer there, refresh it.  Do
version of your application and connect to get
off which
distributor system you want to send
that code to you ok means your distributed system [
music]
show your work ok so you
can rate a repo and you want  Secondly, if all my
colleagues like that, you know, if they
contribute something then it is
very good here, you have already rated one repo,
you have uploaded two files, you
want more contributions, more people
see the files and people contribute.  If you can, then
what you have to do is go to the simple settings,
you can directly request them to give
yours and you can easily create a
community and invite a color printer, the
image and
any add here will be done for you and you.
Easily you know he can contribute
so whatever dates you want you work in
community friends ok so in this video
I just move so much, I am not with you
in the video. If you liked the video then like it
and tell your friends and share it with them.
You can also do it like this, leave the pen drive wala
and no ok gas, so come
I will meet you with you in the new video till then
[Music]